tonight we start again in ukraine where
russia's sickening assault on their
neighbor continues for a fifth straight
day
ukrainian forces have been slowing
putin's advances it's david versus
goliath as they follow the example of
their brave president
when i was running for the president i'd
say that each of us is a president
because all of us carry the
responsibility for our country
for our beautiful ukraine
and now it happened so that each of us
is a warrior
a warrior in his or her right place
and i'm sure that each of us will win
glory to ukraine
today the nation's second largest city
of karkiv faced an intense barrage of
bombings as russia looks to close in on
the country's key population centers the
move mirrors their actions over the
weekend where several cities were also
shelled with russian rockets
putin's forces are being accused of
targeting innocent ukrainian
neighborhoods as the death toll
continues to rise and unfortunately the
worst is yet to come
new satellite images show a major
buildup of russian forces just miles
outside of the capital city of kiev
and earlier today u.s officials
addressed this movement
clearly we continue to see russian
forces
move on or move try to move closer to so
they can move on keeve from the ground
um
we still assess that they're
outside the city center mr putin
still has at his disposal significant
combat power
he hasn't moved all of it into ukraine
but he's moved the majority of it he
still has a lot that he hasn't moved
into ukraine
it's combined arms
and it's not insignificant so putin's
making his move into kiev with even more
troops waiting in the wings as the city
prepares for a bloody siege and this
follows putin's announcement yesterday
that he was putting his nuclear forces
into special combat readiness a
heightened alert status that brings back
memories of the cold war
the state department evaluated this move
earlier
this sort of provocative
rhetoric more than being unnecessary it
is it is dangerous it adds to the risk
of miscalculation it should be
avoided
we are
assessing president putin's directive at
this time as i think you have heard us
say we see no reason to change our own
alert levels but in the face of all this
the world is rushing to ukraine's aid
the u.s and germany have each agreed to
send stinger missiles to their ally
while ukraine has formally applied to
join the european union
and now even switzerland says it's going
to freeze russian assets going against
the nation's long-standing position of
neutrality and international conflicts
luckily these sanctions are having an
effect
as russia's economy crumbles nearly half
of russia's central bank assets have
been frozen in the last 24 hours and the
value of russia's currency the ruble is
in the gutter
hyperinflation could be around the
corner in mother russia
so as fighting and sanctions intensify
negotiations took place in belarus
but peace was hard to find as russia
continues to demand official recognition
of its control of crimea while insisting
ukraine can never ever
join nato
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else